[Music]
most places that we visit show us only
the beauty you opened up and showed us
your honesty I will give you $50 to
stick your head under the blanket
oh okay gang I just got off the phone
with Carson City and it's true the FBI
is coming in to take a look at the
investigation
I make my own meat I make my mate
he's a genius the man knit sweaters out
of human hair it's just got a really
pretty don't know
don't touch the back unfolding scandal
has rocked this city to its core oh my
god you know what I think it is Jim I
think somebody got stabbed in the back
you know I bet if we'd said something he
would have done this and knew the
likeness between Craig and the Truckee
River Killer is eerie but Craig's also
just one of those little weird white
people who looks like serial killers
generate classic piece of the news this
is for chopping off fingers I'm just
kidding
he told me that he would cut my head off
and eat it if I ever needed him to whoa
you're probably wondering why I'm not
around it's because I killed a bunch of
people
you